ragazzi prima di cominciare questo video
volevo dirvi che finalmente il 24 lunedì
24 giugno inizieranno i video sono il
mio secondo canale che è questo che ho
aperto battuto il record il che del
secondo canale lunedì 24 parto coi video
quindi l'esito buona visione
bene da tutti ragazzi e benvenuto questo
video sono faringe registra dati su
geometry desh che quel gioco chiede di
fare le cose mentre la musica va forte e
fa le viuzze quindi lo faccio ragazzi
allora io ho scaricato questo livello
che è un easy demon perché i livelli di
difficoltà su geometrica ci sono tanti
il livello 10 e livello massimo solo che
questo è il facile del livello massimo
no quindi morirò comunque però
proviamoci let's go ragazzi perché io la
patata mela merito non è vero cosa devo
saltare il bianco il nero cosa devo
saltare
spiegami il bianco quindi adesso vado
sul nero e allora tua madre morta
beh ci metterò poco a finire suo livello
ragazzi devo fare qua
[Musica]
ho fatto una cosa che non so come ho
fatto attenzione perché sono stupido ok
ok a posto
non devo volare deve volare
facciamo che cambiamo livello ragazzi
vende il livello piu difficile di geo
metri da sci non lo facciamo facciamone
molto più semplice però mi dispiace
perché era veramente figo purtroppo un
po di ragazze nella mia vita le ho avute
e si vede allora già il fonte bello deve
fare ora il video
cos'è nola per fermi che figata ma cos'è
bellissimo anche rischiando di cadere
pensate
qui buon forget non vorrei non vogliamo
dimenticare non dimentichiamo di quante
volte siamo morti nei livelli in centro
non voglio dimenticare ci manca solo
quello ma che figata
non sa che è bellissimo
avete fatto troppo bene a yeah
poi ci vado un po che ne da andy è semi
stesse zitto quando la musica non è più
musica ma la musica diventa magia fammi
volare sopra le nuvole ci siete
watts umore nostro casinò se muoio rido
tantissimo porco demonio e parlo e parlo
e non sto zitto e sembra aggregata ma
quella parte lì è difficile perché si
trasformi in una navicella e la
navicella non la sua controllare sono
trovare solo la supposta che sono due
cose differenti
la navicella cia tutta la sua fisica che
devi saltare in aria quindi non è così
semplice sensazione incredibile
incredibile la sua controllare la
supposta ragazzi e incredibile come se
non vedo ma siete scemi non vedevo dai
tutto questo ragazzi eravamo arrivati al
77 per cento quindi avevo quasi finito
ma non ancora attenzione è perfetto
sembra facile controllare navicella è
orribile
quando vedo più cosa devo fare della mia
vita adesso sono stupido una cosa che
non di questo gioco che forse non lo
capite e io ve lo a me la spiego perché
io sono capace ospedale cose quando ci
sono le cose automatiche quindi dove non
devi saltare e ancora voi voi pensate è
più facile perché non dedicare niente no
è più difficile perché tu sei abituato a
cliccare quindi non cli chi e quando poi
devi cliccare non critica di quindi è
orribile
quando cioè io preferisco o faccio tutto
io o fai tutto tu non facciamo le vie di
mezzo
perché sennò cadeau nostra roba sembra
una cavolata ragazzi ma il vero di suo
gioco quando mettono le parti che vanno
da sole poi è una cagata perché le
tolgono quando meno te l'aspetti e cani
con un pirla tipo come ho fatto io
adesso sto controllando io mi fermo devo
stare
ok fermo per adesso di schiacciare io
però non me n'ero accorto cioè nel senso
stati proprio i pezzi di schifo tensione
vedo gesù
[Musica]
vabbè è cambiato ma l'attenzione va beh
credo che questo sappia fare livelli la
gorga vacca deve schivare e schivo io
ragazzi questo qua mi sa che è un
livello fatto bene non so come mai ma
geometri dash se ci fate caso è un ep
wings che ce l'ha fatta cioè nel senso è
one piece fatto bene c'è nel senso anche
qui ci ha fatto che questo qua è fatto
proprio musical è bello estivo ostia
lido ho capito ho fatto bene nella
cavità soddisfazione scarino bravo
bianche
grazie che mi indichi dove mi debuttare
se no sarei morto 20 volte perfetto
belli piccioli comunque l'ingegno ancora
così e ciò 24 anni o ragazzi cioè non è
che sia difficile ma almeno non sono
morto
ho detto strano in genere quando l'unico
muoio iniziano virgola tre secondi però
vabbè o primo tentativo ci voglio
credere
potrebbe essere
[Musica]
proprio lui che allora era facile però
non da un tentativo solo stavolta
normale dai bravo bravo bravo dj prof
allora ragazzi facciamo i seri più bello
sta canzone si è questa qua non era
quella di the impossible game qualcuno
esperto di voi me lo sa dire se quella
canzoni prossimo chiedono messa in
vetrina
paolo livello un po meno bello livello
per la canzone bella fai a venezia sul
posto a fi a vedere vai zio barca
laccata ragazzi porca vacca almeno
questo comunque secondo me questo solo
perché c'è la musica di impossibile che
annuncia la faccio perché la musica dei
nel prossimo che mi ha sempre caricato
visto con un detto perché io sapevo
farla con la parte sono andato sbattere
la faccia dritto contro il muro perché
la che me lo chiedono attenzione buono
ora vogliamo o mio dio
e va beh sì sì sono contento di come ho
fatto
peccato perché la distruzione del gruppo
e un orgasmo mancato lo so mi dispiace
però sono scarsi allora carichi jerry
sostituti biscotti
[Applauso]
[Musica]
cos'è cos'è me gioca da metto un
cartello dove sta scritto ad esso
diventi una supposta quindi rischia poi
lo so io cosa faccio però screen il melò
perché non lo so se non muoio prima
mannaia tema ok buono buono
perfetto rispetto questo per la
concentrazione non perderla non perda
non perderla non perderla non perderla
90 per cento
maledizione tavolo alla fine ce la posso
fare ragazzi aree si era arrivato lì c'è
lo salva
[Musica]
[Applauso]
acquistate le magliette fa vincere le
trovi in descrizioni quindi ragazzi
questo era sono fortissimo i ragazzi
questo ragionamento di dash di oggi
spero che vi sia piaciuto fare un altro
episodio la prossima settimana iscritti
via canale per nuovissimi video e
schiacciate la campanella per rimanere
aggiornati sui video viaggio e noi come
sempre ragazzi ci rivediamo ad un
prossimo video da ragazzi
[Musica]